[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to it seems that not even a show
cancellation can stop the devil himself
with the titular Lucifer returning to
our screens through Netflix the show is
here for its fourth season and there's a
hell of a lot to unpack from eight
throughout this video I'll be breaking
down everything that you need to know
about the show's fourth season as well
as what I took from its finale this is
full spoilers ahead so if you haven't
had a chance to watch it yet and don't
want to know what happens then I highly
suggest that you turn off now with that
out the way a huge thank you for
clicking this video now sit back relax
and let's get into my and they explain
breakdown of Lucifer's season for the
main focus of season four is centered
around the conflict that Chloe feels
after discovering the dark side of
Lucifer in the finale of season 3 though
she still loves him she questions
whether she ever really knew him at all
after seeing his true face and this of
course is a metaphor for relationships
that slowly start to fall apart upon the
discovery of a huge secret this is a
true case of better the devil you know
with Chloe attempting to get along with
the character whilst also attacking her
own prejudices that she attempts to
overcome and deal with though it seems
unlikely that she can this further
distances Lucifer from our world as he
was already struggling to gain a
connection to it and this plays into the
season finale Lucifer has shown his true
side to someone he deeply cares about
and has been pretty heavily rejected
because of it and therefore doesn't
really feel welcome anymore I mean in
real life how many relationships have
caused one side of the partnership to be
an outcast after they have shown a
certain side of themselves be a
political or religious stance or
something more Lucifer has to deal with
this feeling of unrequited Ness - either
season and he really struggles because
of
the introduction of Eve spirals him away
from Chloe and this little temptation
that of course is tie into the biblical
Garden of Eden slowly turns him away
from the person that he was becoming
whilst it seems that Lucifer is finally
rid of Eve at the end she summons demons
that want to see the return of the king
and will do whatever it takes getting
back
Eve has been plotting this entire time
to take him back to the underworld so
that the prophecy of Hell taking
overhead can be fulfilled
the demons unlike Lucifer do not share
his love or understanding for the
surface and can't really grasp why he
wouldn't want to go back they have other
plans though and kidnap a child in order
to raise and brainwash it to become the
new ruler of hell and this puts Lucifer
at a stalemate if he does not act then
the prophecy will come true and he will
be useless and attempting to stop it
after confessing his love to Chloe
he returns to the throne of Hell and
therefore his rightful position Lucifer
could never escape destiny or his true
self and though he attempted to divert
it away from it no matter what he was
always destined to end up back there
this is a true struggle of life and it
showcases that sometimes no matter how
much we try and make things work they
just won't well do you think Lucifer
will eventually return it's a rather
bleak note to end the show on it's still
showcased that sometimes we cannot
escape our past hell needs a king
however I do think that you will
struggle to fit in with this and will
always try and get back home the second
part of the season is due to release
later in the air and it will no doubt
deal with this conflict that he has over
whether to return to Earth or stay where
he belongs
obviously there's a lot that can be
taken from this and I'd love to hear
your thoughts on the show and what you
think will happen in the future
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoy this video then please like it
make sure you check out my breakdown of
the newly released watchmen teaser
trailer which will be linked at the end
this is the channel for people who are
never missing television so if that's
the kind of thing you like you need to
subscribe to definition thanks again for
taking the time to watch this you've
been the best and
take care peace
[Music]